bonjour aujourd'hui je vais vous
présenter laurent binet avec la septième
fonctions du langage c'est son dernier
roman paru chez grasset donc le
préambule du livre c'est roland barthes
qui traverse la rue devant un collège de
france et qui se fait écraser par une
camionnette de blanchissages et là en
fait il tenait dans ses mains un
manuscrit sur lequel il travaillait
depuis un long moment qui est un
manuscrit qui permettent de décrypter en
fait les fonctions du langage et cette
fonction-là permet en fait de faire un
peu ce qu'on veut avec les food donc de
manipuler les foules et de les emmener
là où on est donc ce manuscrit lorsqu'il
se fait écraser
il se fait voler et donc tous le livre
commence en fait au départ sur cette
enquête là où pourquoi on a tué roland
barthes et qui veut sur l'année ce cri
qui est tellement secret donc pour mener
cette enquête on va mettre inconnu
commissaire poujadiste totalement
hermétique à toute cette vie cette vie
étudiante et culturelle des années 70 et
pour l'accompagner on va mettre un petit
1 tizen prof de fac qui va l'accompagner
qui va décréter justement tous les codes
de cette société qui est pour lui
totalement secrète mais ce commissaire
va donc croiser toute la société
culturelle et intellectuelle des années
70 donc il va croiser derrida il va
croiser bhl dans ses jeunes années va
croiser sollers va croiser là quand il
va croiser john borg aussi il va croiser
mitterrand voilà il va croiser tout ce
monde là toute cette vie intellectuelle
la des années 70 et 80
c'est vraiment très drôle et très bien
écrit le point aussi importante du
bouquin c'est qu'il ya un moment il va
tomber sur une société secrète un peu à
la fight club dont envers toi et quoi
sera le héros
delphine navigant a eu beaucoup beaucoup
de retombées médiatiques à la sortie de
son précédent roman qui était rien ne
s'oppose à la nuit c'est un livre sur la
bipolarité de sa mère et elle en a
ressenti les effets assez rapidement ça
a été quelque chose de très lourd de
très difficile pour elle et à tel point
qu'elle n'arrivait plus du tout à écrire
et à chaque fois qu'elle croisait
quelqu'un qu'elle connaissait ou un
lecteur quelqu'un qui a aimé son livre
on lui demandait alors quand est-ce que
vous en écrivez un nouveau et elle est
vraiment dans l'impossibilité même
physique d'en écrire à nouveau elle peut
plus approcher de son ordinateur elle ne
peut plus écrire
jusqu'au jour où par hasard à une soirée
va rencontrer une certaine l on ajuste
son initiale et cette femme va
bouleverser sa vie
ça devient sa meilleure amie un peut du
jour au lendemain elle c'est absolument
tout de delphine de vigan l écoute
elle l'a conseil a eu quelques coups de
pied aux fesses pour qu'elle se remette
à écrire et à la fois elle est assez la
vampirette on peut dire que la
vampiriser
et elle va prendre prendre peu à peu une
part beaucoup trop importante dans sa
vie c'est intéressant dans ce roman
c'est que tout au long du récit on se
pose la question de est ce que c'est
elle existe vraiment puisque c'est une
invention de l'auteur est-ce que c'est
effectivement une personne néfastes ou
plutôt bénéfique pour l'écriture de
delphine de vigan
voilà je pense que je vous en ai déjà
dit beaucoup trop alors il ya une
beaucoup de livres qui sortent
actuellement sur le tricentenaire de la
mort de louis xiv et donc nous on en a
sélectionné un parmi ceux là donc c'est
celui ci qui raconte finalement les
dames les 17 derniers jours de la vie du
roi est roi soleil on lit habituellement
toute sa vie avant ses dix sept jours là
donc tous ses fastes la construction du
château la vie avec la reine où la vie
avec ses maîtresses mais on a rarement
le pan de lorsque louis xiv finalement
était en détresse et avait des vraies
douleurs donc là ce livre va détailler
justement toute cette partie là de sa
vie qui avait finalement très peu connu
et donc le bouquin est dissocié en deux
parties dont il ya les parties doux
l'auteur décrit tout ce qu'il vit durant
sa journée donc tout ce que la cour peut
lui apporter
et toutes les parties qui sont aussi qui
concerne la nuit où là on va le roi
repart en introspection avec dieu avec
tous finalement tout ce qu'il a pu vivre
par ailleurs c'est une vision qui n'est
pas habituel delà de ce qu'on peut avoir
comme comme vue sur le roi soleil
finalement donc cette vision d'un homme
qui à la gangrène qui le ronge
totalement les eaux et finalement qui a
et qui a beaucoup de doutes
alors il a fait beaucoup de guerre il ya
eu beaucoup de beaucoup de choses dans
sa vie où il avait des idées très
arrêtées elle a finalement ils se sont
un peu perdus quand on finalement arrive
la fin de sa vie c'est un premier roman
un peu particulier si on sait pas
vraiment renseigné sur l'auteur on pense
lire un roman américain alors que c'est
écrit par un ancien libraire
on va suivre toute une flopée de
personnages à différentes époques et
dans différentes villes aux états unis
on a par exemple dû dwayne qui tente de
sauver un petit garçon de sa mère
violente
un jeune homme qui met le feu à la
maison de ses parents alors que ses
parents sont toujours deux dans une
jeune serveuse qui tente désespérément
d'échapper à son passé et petit à petit
tout tous ces personnages qui ont eu
l'enfant ce premier traumatisante qui
vivent une vie un peu cauchemardesque
vont se retrouver prisonnier de la même
toile et c'est la toile d'un mal
beaucoup plus puissants que tout ce
qu'ils ont pu connaître jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement bien écrit
c'est maîtrisé c'est une description
d'une amérique profonde qu'est la fois
plein plein d' espaces de nature et puis
qui est extrêmement glauque finalement
et en même temps on s'attache à tous ces
personnages on sait pas trop si
ils ce sont les loups ou les moutons
dans l'histoire s'alternent assez
souvent et on a vraiment l'impression de
vivre de lire un roman américain il ya
une côté fantastique un côté road movie
aussi c'est vraiment une belle réussite
et je pense que c'est un auteur très
prometteur